Lors du célèbre premier appel téléphonique de l'histoire,
Alexander Graham Bell a dit:
"Allô, je suis bien chez Domino's Pizza?"
(Rires)
Je veux juste vous dire un grand merci.
Et comme l'a dit un autre homme célèbre, Jerry Garcia:
"Quel long et étrange voyage."
Il aurait plutôt dû dire:
"Quel long et étrange voyage, c'est en train de devenir."
A cet instant, vous voyez le haut de mon corps.
Le bas tient une autre conférence ailleurs,
(Rires)
dans un autre pays.
En fait, on peut être à deux endroits en même temps.
Malgré tout, je regrette de ne pouvoir être parmi vous.
Je vous expliquerai plus tard.
Même si je suis une rock star,
je vous assure que je n'ai pas demandé de jacuzzi.
Mais ce que je trouve excitant dans le domaine technologique
ce n'est pas simplement la capacité de stocker plus de chansons sur un lecteur mp3.
La révolution, cette révolution, est beaucoup plus spectaculaire.
J'espère, j'y crois.
Ce qui est stimulant dans l'ère numérique,
ce que je trouve stimulant
c'est que vous avez comblé le fossé entre le rêve et la réalité.
Avant, pour faire une chanson,
vous aviez besoin d'un studio et d'un producteur.
Aujourd'hui, vous avez juste besoin d'un ordinateur portable.
Si vous vouliez réaliser un film, il fallait un équipement énorme
et un budget hollywoodien.
Aujourd'hui, vous avez juste besoin d'une caméra
et de quelques dollars pour acheter un DVD vierge.
L'imagination s'est vue libérée de toutes ces vieilles contraintes.
Et je trouve ça vraiment très excitant.
Je suis enthousiaste en imaginant ce type de pensée à grande échelle.
J'aimerais que l'idéalisme se libère de toute contrainte,
politique, économique, psychologique, etc.
La géopolitique a beaucoup à apprendre du monde numérique
dans la manière de surmonter les obstacles
que l'on pensait ne jamais pouvoir surmonter.
Et c'est le thème de mon intervention.
D'abord, il faut que j'explique pourquoi et comment
je me suis retrouvé là.
C'est un voyage qui a débuté il y a 20 ans.
Vous vous souvenez probablement de la chanson "We are the world,"
ou de "Do They Know It's Christmas?"
de Band Aid ou Live Aid.
Une autre star, grisonnante et de petite taille, mon ami Sir Bob Geldof
a lancé un défi: "nourrir le monde."
Ce fut un moment historique qui a totalement changé ma vie.
Cet été-là, ma femme Ali et moi-même sommes partis en Ethiopie.
Nous sommes partis incognito pour voir la réalité des choses.
Nous avons passé un mois en Ethiopie à travailler dans un orphelinat.
Les enfants m'ont donné un nom.
Ils m'ont surnommé "la fille à barbe".
(Rires)
Sans commentaire.
Mais nous avons trouvé que l'Afrique est un endroit magique.
Des cieux immenses, des coeurs immenses, un continent immense et radieux.
Des gens magnifiques et dignes.
Quiconque a donné à l'Afrique se l'est vu rendre au centuple.
L'Ethiopie ne m'a pas juste ému, elle m'a ouvert l'esprit.
Et le dernier jour, à l'orphelinat,
un homme m'a tendu son bébé et m'a dit:
"Est ce que vous pourriez emmener mon fils avec vous?"
Il savait qu'en Irlande, son fils survivrait.
En Ethiopie, son fils mourrait.
On était en pleine famine.
Mais j'ai refusé.
J'ai eu une impression de malaise mais j'ai refusé.
Et cette impression est encore là.
C'est à ce moment-là que mon voyage a commencé.
A ce moment-là, je suis devenu la pire des créatures:
une rock star portant une cause...
mais ce n'est pas une cause.
Six mille cinq cents Africains meurent chaque jour du SIDA,
une maladie que l'on peut éviter et traiter
parce que les médicaments ne se trouvent pas dans n'importe quelle pharmacie.
Ce n'est pas une cause. C'est une urgence.
11 millions d'orphelins du SIDA en Afrique.
20 millions d'ici 2010.
Ce n'est pas une cause. C'est une urgence.
Aujourd'hui, chaque jour, 9000 nouvelles personnes en Afrique
contracteront le VIH par la stigmatisation et le manque d'éducation.
Ce n'est pas une cause. C'est une urgence.
Ce dont nous parlons ici, ce sont les Droits de l'Homme,
le droit de vivre comme un être humain.
Le droit de vivre, point final.
Et en Afrique, nous faisons face à
une menace nouvelle à la dignité et à l'égalité des hommes.
Je voudrais aussi faire une distinction
sur ce problème,
parce qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une oeuvre caritative.
Il s'agit de justice. Vraiment.
Nous ne parlons pas de caritatif mais de justice.
Voilà.
Et c'est dommage parce que nous sommes bons en caritatif.
Les Américains, les Irlandais sont bons en caritatif.
Les quartiers les plus miséreux donnent plus qu'ils ne devraient.
Nous aimons donner et nous donnons beaucoup.
Regardez les réactions après le tsunami, c'est vraiment formidable.
Mais la justice est un projet plus ardu que le caritatif.
L'Afrique ridiculise notre idée de justice.
Elle ridiculise notre idée de l'égalité.
Elle se moque de nos croyances, elle remet en question nos convictions.
Elle interroge nos engagements,
parce qu'il n'y a pas de moyen de regarder l'Afrique
en étant honnête
et de se dire que partout ailleurs, la situation serait insupportable.
Comme vous l'avez vu dans le film, partout ailleurs, pas ici.
Pas ici, pas aux Etats-Unis, pas en Europe.
D'ailleurs, un chef d'Etat que vous connaissez
m'a avoué cela. Et c'est la vérité.
Il n'y a aucun doute sur le fait qu'une telle proportion de pertes humaines
puisse être acceptée ailleurs qu'en Afrique.
L'Afrique est en flammes.
Et au fond, si nous acceptions vraiment que les Africains soient nos égaux,
nous ferions plus qu'éteindre l'incendie.
Nous avons des arrosoirs
quand il faudrait une brigade de pompiers.
Ce n'est pas aussi spectaculaire que le tsunami.
C'est fou quand on y pense.
Faut-il désormais que ces choses-là ressemblent à un film d'action
pour que nous nous rendions compte ?
Le long décompte des vies perdues
n'est semble-t-il tout simplement pas assez spectaculaire .
Les catastrophes que nous pouvons éviter
ne sont pas aussi intéressantes que celles que nous pourrions éviter.
C'est amusant.
En tout cas, je crois que cette manière de penser
insulte la rigueur intellectuelle de cette salle.
Six mille cinq cents morts chaque jour, c' est peut-être le reflet d'une crise africaine
mais le fait que nous n'en fassions pas la une,
que l'Europe ou l'Amérique
ne traitent pas ce sujet comme une urgence,
laissez-moi vous opposer ce soir l'idée qu'il s'agit bien de notre crise.
Je veux opposer l'idée que l'Afrique n'est en effet pas la ligne de front d'une guerre contre la terreur
mais elle pourrait bientôt le devenir.
Chaque semaine, des extrémistes religieux s'emparent d'un nouveau village d'Afrique.
Ils essaient de ramener l'ordre.
Pourquoi n'y arrivons-nous pas?
La pauvreté nourrit le désespoir. C'est un fait.
Le désespoir nourrit la violence. C'est aussi un fait.
Dans des périodes troublées, n'est-il pas plus facile et plus intelligent
de s'associer à nos ennemis potentiels
plutôt que de risquer d'avoir à se défendre contre eux plus tard?
La guerre contre la terreur est intimement liée à la guerre contre la pauvreté.
Ce n'est pas de moi, c'est Colin Powell qui a prononcé ces mots.
Aussi si un militaire nous dit que c'est une guerre
qu'on ne peut gagner seulement avec les armes,
peut-être faudrait-il l'écouter.
Il y a une chance à saisir, une vraie chance.
Il ne s'agit pas d'un tour de magie ou d'un voeu pieux.
Les problèmes des pays en voie de développement
donnent une opportunité à nos pays développés
de se redéfinir vis-à-vis du monde.
Nous ne transformerons pas seulement la vie des autres,
nous transformerons aussi la vision qu'ils ont de nous.
Et c'est sans doute un bon calcul dans ces périodes troublées.
Ne croyez-vous pas que sur le seul plan commercial,
les médicaments rétroviraux ne seraient pas une promotion
de l'ingéniosité et de la technologie occidentale?
La compassion nous va-t-elle si mal?
Arrêtons les conneries une seconde.
Dans certaines parties du monde, les échanges commerciaux européens ou américains
ne sont pas au mieux.
Le néon clignote et se fissure.
Quelqu'un a lancé un pavé dans la vitrine.
Les directeurs de filiales deviennent nerveux.
Jamais auparavant l'Occident n'a été autant observé.
Nos valeurs: en avons-nous?
Notre crédibilité?
Ces valeurs sont attaquées dans le monde entier.
Les marques américaines auraient bien besoin d'un coup de jeune.
Et je parle en tant que fan,
en tant que client de ces marques.
Mais réfléchissez.
Fournir davantage d'anti-rétroviraux a un sens.
Mais c'est la partie la plus facile et elle a lieu d'être.
Mais l'égalité pour l'Afrique,
est un concept énorme et coûteux.
Un tel degré de souffrance nous mène vers une sorte d'indifférence.
Que pouvons-nous faire?
Eh bien, certainement plus que nous pensons.
Nous ne pouvons pas tout résoudre, mais ce qui peut être fait,
j'insiste, nous devons le faire.
Et parce que nous pouvons, nous en avons l'obligation.
C'est la stricte vérité, une vérité morale.
Il ne s'agit pas d'une théorie.
En fait, nous sommes la première génération
confrontée à regarder en face la maladie et l'extrême pauvreté,
à voir l'Afrique et à dire ceci et à le penser.
Nous ne pouvons pas laisser faire ça.
Nous ne pouvons pas laisser un continent entier disparaître.
(Applaudissements)
Laissez-moi vous dire ceci, sans la moindre ironie
avant que j'en parle à une bande d'ex-hippies.
Oubliez les années 60. Nous pouvons changer le monde.
Vous ou moi, en tant qu'individu, ne pouvons pas mais tous ensemble nous pouvons changer le monde.
Je crois en cela, nous tous ici présents.
Regardez la fondation Gates.
Ils ont réalisé des choses incroyables.
En travaillant tous ensemble, nous pouvons vraiment changer le monde.
Nous pouvons changer les choses
et améliorer la qualité de vie de millions d'êtres humains
qui nous ressemblent et ressentent les mêmes choses que nous.
Pardon de rire mais vous tous paraissez si différents
de ce que vous étiez dans le quartier de Haight-Ashbury dans les années 60.
(Rires)
Mais je veux dire que c'est le moment où vous intervenez.
C'est le moment où les plantes que vous avez semées vont fleurir
à une époque ancienne et grisante.
Les idées que vous avez fait naître dans votre jeunesse.
C'est ce que je trouve stimulant.
Cet endroit existe pour cet instant,
c'est vraiment ce que je veux vous dire ce soir.
Beaucoup d'entre vous ont commencé parce qu'ils voulaient changer le monde, n'est ce pas?
Beaucoup l'ont fait par le monde numérique.
Eh bien maintenant, avec vous,
il est possible de changer le monde physique.
C'est un fait.
Les économistes le confirment et ils en savent plus que moi.
Alors pourquoi ne pouvons-nous pas?
probablement parce que lorsqu'on admet que nous pouvons faire quelque chose,
nous nous devons de le faire.
C'est chiant.
Le business de l'égalité est chiant.
Mais pour la première fois dans l'histoire, nous disposons de la technologie,
du savoir-faire, de l'argent,
des traitements médicaux.
Mais avons-nous la volonté?
Je pense que c'est clair mais je ne suis pas un hippie.
Et je ne suis pas du genre nostalgique.
Je ne porte pas de fleurs dans les cheveux
Je suis plus dans le punk rock.
Les Clash portaient des rangers, pas des sandales.
Mais je sais reconnaître la dureté.
Et à chaque parole de paix et d'amour de la côte ouest
le mouvement qui a commencé ici parlait avec ses poings.
L'idéalisme détaché de l'action n'est qu'un rêve.
Mais l'idéalisme allié au pragmatisme,
le fait de se relever les manches et de changer un peu ce monde
est très excitant, très concret, très fort.
Et c'est très présent dans une audience comme la vôtre.
L'an dernier avec DATA, cette organisation que j'ai aidé à créer,
nous avons initié une campagne pour créer cet esprit
dans le combat contre le Sida et la pauvreté extrême.
Nous l'avons appelé campagne ONE.
Elle est basée sur l'idée que l'action d'une personne
peut changer les choses
mais les actions de plusieurs personnes ensemble et unies
peuvent changer le monde.
Eh bien nous pensons que désormais il faut prouver que nous sommes dans le vrai.
Il est des moments dans l'histoire où la civilisation se redéfinit.
Nous pensons que nous en sommes là,
que nous pourrions être à un moment où le monde décide enfin
que la perte de tant de vies en Afrique n'est plus acceptable.
Ce pourrait être le moment où nous nous décidons enfin
de changer le futur de la plupart des gens qui vivent sur la planète Terre.
L'impulsion se fait.
Elle vacille un peu mais elle se fait.
Cette année est un test pour nous tous
et surtout pour les leaders du G8
qui sont les premiers concernés
car le monde les regarde.
J'ai été déçu par l'Administration Bush ces derniers temps.
Ils ont fait tant de promesses à l'Afrique.
Ils ont fait de grandes promesses
et en ont tenu plusieurs.
Et d'autres pas.
Ils n'ont pas conscience de cette impulsion. C'est la réalité.
Mais ma déception est atténuée
quand je parle à des Américains
et qu'ils me parlent de leurs déficits
et du bien-être fiscal de leur pays,
ce que je comprends.
Mais l'impulsion serait plus forte que vous le pensez
si nous nous nous organisions.
Ce que j'essaie de dire, et vous pouvez m'aider si vous êtes d'accord
c'est que l'aide envers l'Afrique est rentable
dans une période où l'Amérique a besoin de rentabilité.
En disant ça en termes horriblement cyniques,
le retour sur investissement est énorme.
Non seulement des vies seront sauvés mais en termes de bonne volonté, de stabilité
et de sécurité nous serons gagnants.
Alors pour être audacieux, c'est le voeu que je formule
en espérant qu'il ne soit pas décompté de ma liste de voeux.
(Rires)
Ce que j'espère, au-delà d'actions altruistes individuelles
c'est que vous direz à vos représentants politiques de bien agir en Afrique,
en Amérique et dans le monde.
Donnez-leur le droit, si vous préférez,
de consacrer leur capital politique et vos capitaux,
votre richesse nationale pour sauver la vie de millions de gens.
C'est vraiment ce que je veux faire.
Et nous avons aussi besoin de votre capital intellectuel,
de vos idées, de vos compétences, de votre inventivité.
Et vous, ici, êtes dans une position unique.
Certaines des technologies dont nous parlons, vous les avez inventées
ou au moins révolutionné la manière de les utiliser.
Ensemble vous avez transformé l'analogique en digital
et repoussé les frontières.
Et nous voulons que vous nous transmettiez cette énergie.
Offrez-nous ce rêve et ce savoir faire.
Et comme je disais, il y a deux choses à prendre en compte.
Il y a le continent africain.
Et il y a aussi notre conscience.
Les gens commencent à le comprendre.
Le mouvement est en train de naître:
artistes, politiciens, pop stars, prêtres, PDG,
ONG, des associations de mères et d'étudiants.
Les gens s'unissent et travaillent
sous la bannière dont je vous ai parlé, la campagne ONE.
Et la seule idée qu'ils portent
est la suivante: l'endroit où vous vivez dans le monde,
ne détermine pas votre manière d'exister dans ce monde.
(Applaudissements)
L'Histoire, comme Dieu, nous observe.
Quand notre histoire s'écrira dans les livres
je pense que trois éléments resteront.
Je crois que notre époque marquera l'histoire en trois points.
La révolution numérique.
La guerre contre le terrorisme.
et ce que nous aurons fait ou pas pour sauver l'Afrique.
Certains pensent que nous n'en avons pas les moyens, je crois que nous n'avons pas les moyens de l'éviter.
Merci, merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Ok, mes trois voeux.
Ceux que TED a proposé de récompenser.
S'il est vrai, comme je le crois,
que le monde numérique que vous avez créé va libérer
l'imagination des contraintes physiques.
Ca devrait être quelque peu merdique.
(Rires)
Je dois ajouter que la liste était beaucoup plus longue.
La plupart étaient irréalisables,
et un ou deux étaient certainement inavouables.
(Rires)
Ce business devient addictif, vous savez de quoi je parle,
quand quelqu'un d'autre paie l'addition.
Bref, voici le numéro un.
Je souhaite que vous aidiez à construire un mouvement social
de plus d'un million de militants pour l'Afrique.
C'est mon premier voeu.
Je pense qu'il est réalisable.
Il y a quelques minutes, je parlais des campagnes citoyennes qui sont en train de naître.
Il y en a beacoup vous savez.
Et grâce à la campagne ONE,
mon organisation, DATA et d'autres groupes
ont puisé l'énergie et l'enthousiasme
d'Hollywood jusqu'au coeur de l'Amérique.
Nous savons que pour soutenir ce mouvement, ce n'est pas l'énergie qui manque.
Nous avons juste besoin de vous pour le lancer.
Nous voulons que vous tous, l'église, les entreprises,
Microsoft, Apple, Coca Cola,
Pepsi, l'Amérique des informaticiens, l'Amérique bruyante.
On ne peut pas se permettre de rester là à attendre.
Je crois que si nous créons un mouvement fort d'un million d'Américains
nous ne pourrons pas être ignorés.
Le Congrès nous regardera.
Condoleeza Rice nous inscrira dans son agenda
et la Maison Blanche en fera autant.
SI un million d'Américains, et j'en suis certain,
sont prêts à téléphoner,
à envoyer des mails,
je suis certain que l'on peut modifier
le cours de l'histoire et le sort de l'Afrique.
En tout cas, j'aimerais aider ce mouvement.
Je sais que John Gage et Sun Microsystems sont déjà partants
mais nous aimerions nous adresser à nombre d'entre vous.
Ok, mon deuxième voeu, le numéro deux.
J'aimerais qu'il y ait un seul clic média pour chaque être humain
qui vit avec moins d'un dollar par jour.
C'est un milliard de clics.
Cela peut se faire avec Google, avec AOL,
Steve Case, Larry, Sergey. Ils ont déjà beaucoup fait.
Ce peut-être NBC ou ABC.
D'ailleurs, nous discutons avec ABC en ce moment à propos des Oscars.
Nous avons un film produit par Jon Karmen pour Radical Media.
Mais nous avons d'une exposition médiatique pour faire connaître nos idées.
Nous avons besoin de chiffres et de statistiques pour les soumettre aux Américains.
Je crois en la vieille idée de Truman,
qui dit que si vous donnez les faits au peuple américain,
ils prendront la bonne décision.
Et l'autre point important, c'est qu'on ne parle pas de Sally Struthers.
Ceci doit être perçu comme une aventure ,pas un fardeau.
(Video): Un à un, ils nous rejoignent,
une infirmière, un enseignant, un constructeur
et des vies sont sauvées.
Le problème est énorme.
Une personne meurt toutes les trois secondes.
Trois secondes de plus, une autre meurt.
La situation est si désespérée dans certaines parties de l'Afrique,
d'Asie ou même d'Amérique,
que des groupes d'aide, comme pour le tsunami,
s'unissent et agissent dans le même sens.
Nous pouvons combattre la pauvreté, la famine, le Sida.
Mais nous avons besoin de vous.
Une autre personne, une lettre, une voix
distinguera la vie de la mort
pour des millions de personnes.
S'il vous plaît, rejoignez-vous et travaillons ensemble.
L'Amérique a une chance inédite
de construire l'Histoire.
Nous pouvons commencer à faire de la pauvreté de l' histoire ancienne.
Un par un.
Allez voir le site ONE à cette adresse.
Nous ne demandons pas d'argent. Nous voulons vous entendre.
Bono: Je souhaite à TED de vraiment montrer le pouvoir de l'information.
Il a le pouvoir de réécrire les règles et de transformer nos vies
en connectant chaque hôpital, chaque clinique et école
dans un pays d'Afrique.
Et j'aimerais que ce soit en Ethiopie
je crois qu'on peut connecter chaque école d'Ethiopie,
chaque clinique, chaque hôpital.
Nous pouvons nous connecter à Internet.
C'est mon souhait, le troisième.
Je crois que c'est possible.
Nous avons l'argent et la connaisance dans cette salle pour y parvenir.
Et ce serait extraordinaire que ce voeu devienne réalité.
Je suis allé en Ethiopie, je l'ai dit.
C'est là que tout a commencé pour moi.
L'idée qu'Internet, qui a tant transformé nos vies,
puisse transformer un pays, et un continent
qui a à peine découvert les connections analogiques, me renverse.
Mais ça n'a pas commencé comme ça.
La première connexion téléphonique longue distance entre Boston et New York
a été utilisée en 1885.
A Addis Abeba, ça s'est passé à peine neuf ans plus tard
par une connexion avec Harare, à 500 kms de là.
Depuis, ça n'a pas beaucoup évolué.
Le temps d'attente moyen pour obtenir une ligne téléphonique fixe en Ethiopie
est d'environ sept à huit ans.
Mais la technologie sans fil était inimaginable.
Moi je suis Irlandais. Comme vous voyez,
je connais l'importance de la parole.
La communication est très importante en Ethiopie et transformera le pays.
Les infirmières seront mieux formées,
les pharmaciens pourront commander des médicaments,
les médecins pourront partager leurs connaissances dans tous les domaines médicaux.
Il est vraiment très important qu'ils soient connectés.
Et c'est le troisième et dernier voeu que j'adresse à cette conférence TED.
Merci encore.
(Applaudissements)